what's happening there reject nation we
got ourselves a trailer for the newest
predator movie called pray you can leave
a like that'd be very much appreciated
i'm looking forward to this one director
of 10 cloverfield lane it's going to be
coming out of hulu so that means we'll
probably do a movie reaction for it so
with that in mind with all the extra
editing and help that we have been
hiring want to thank today's video
sponsor so we've been partnering up with
athletic greens to be more about them
after the reaction first let's check out
this trailer
[Music]
girl kyle looks like aubry blossom
oh no i don't say that
won't be able to see it
oh that's it
now give me more that's a great teaser
that is a terrific test that's like
teasers from back in the day yeah yeah
nowadays that's a trailer for a trailer
yeah right yeah stay tuned right now but
yeah no it takes me back to that i don't
think that other girl looked like the
one without the eye shadow no i i i said
like i'm not gonna be able to unsee it
i thought you said don't say that yeah
because now i won't be able to unsee it
i thought i liked it i said something
offensive nah you're fine yeah re-shoot
a reaction
that way oh that was a great teaser i
got a lot of thoughts on that absolutely
before we go into that we're from our
sponsor thank you to athletic greens for
partnering up with us this month well
the schedule is wild as ours it's tough
to stay on top of proper diet and
nutrition luckily athletic greens eg1
formula makes your daily nutrition
simple delicious inconvenient get bigger
just one scoop contains 75 high quality
vitamins minerals probiotics and a whole
bunch more which supports gut health
nervous and immune systems energy focus
plus on a serious note ag-1 is lifestyle
friendly i'm actually allergic to dairy
so any shake i ever have has to be
dairy-free
so whether you eat keto paleo vegan
dairy-free or gluten-free it's a good
fit plus it's completely natural no
harmful chemicals or gmos and for my
sake it helps improve my sleep quality
and mental clarity which is always a
boost it helps improve my gut health i
like to poop and i like saving money and
what's great about athletic greens is
your subscription only costs about three
dollars a day that's double what i paid
john and it comes with a year supply of
vitamin d and all that is way cheaper
than trying to get all these supplements
individually so head on over to
athleticgreens.com to start your ag-1
lifestyle today yeah i mean this brought
it back to that original flair just of
so much like pure tension because the
the predator franchise has devolved into
just whack dude
especially lately yeah it's silly action
sci-fi and this felt like very grounded
just human hunter versus predator i mean
this is a prequel right so it takes
place
um
in the past what are the native
americans i believe so that's certainly
how they look to me but maybe i'm an
ignorant white man i'm actually
remembering some of the controversy
surrounding this movie now too because
there was a short film that felt very
akin to this that was a predator fan
film and then they went ahead and made
this but didn't offer up any
contribution financially to the person
who made the short film if i'm not
mistaken awesome it's good business it's
all coming back to me now
screaming this
yeah this is totally like native
american character fighting predators oh
no wow
oh dang that's crazy you're both pretty
from blinky 500 is the channel will
everybody go watch that short yeah the
top comment is i hope you're getting
compensation from disney in 20th century
for ripping off your phone from that
star wars girl this video is taking a
turn
that was a really great treat
they need it to be a great trailer if
they're going to crush this controversy
before it really pops off i mean putting
that to the side what this trailer did
was really emit a genuine horror vibe
something that doesn't feel like it's
trying anything by being super flashy
you're just out in nature fighting it
feels very primal that's what predator
ought to be especially for like a modern
day touch to it especially we're gonna
go woke
up woman fighting
women fighting predators that's the key
get woke but 300 years ago yeah
isolate two people she's got no choice
you can't argue with that even from just
this little tease i mean she looks like
she has a whole lot of presents it makes
me wonder and it almost makes me hope
for something that's like more isolated
than like the previous predator movies
always have some kind of ensemble and
that's part of the fun ooh all these
different quirky characters but i feel
like here you could do something kind of
new and different by just focusing in on
one person and one predator or maybe a
couple but keeping it yeah that isolated
paranoid like there's no place to hide
there's no power in numbers i was
looking for uh to see if there's a new
predator image out there and the
cinematography is also excellent it
really has that dread like i like seeing
dan trachtenberg in this scenario
because it's like 10 cloverfield lane is
like a bottle it's really tight knit
quarters whereas this is a big massive
film yeah yeah this is just you know
broad expanse of emptiness you know well
it's a very reliant on atmosphere not
rely on any music or familiar stings i
thought was a great call especially for
your first real look at this movie yeah
no ironic cover song what if it's a
female predator oh now that's too woke
for me with like big boobies that's
right yeah she goes around in like a
predator swimsuit it really shows off
all of her unique curves and then at the
end we can see uh
you know i'm not going to make that
trigger wears makeup yeah that's better
that's better than where i was headed
with this
just imagine their mouths but elsewhere
what i'm really curious to see unfold in
this movie is actually how is the hunt
gonna go down how's the violence gonna
go down with the predator locking on
that would imply the predator ain't
using you know freaking a bow and arrow
it's like the burgers it definitely has
like this laser gun thing whatever it's
called this time period the more the
weapons are more blade like right blades
and arrows and spears and things yeah
yeah so i'd feel like the predator all
he has to do or she whichever gender the
predator is they yeah non-binary
if it locks like just shoots them
right there like right away yeah like
what is the predator gonna limit itself
the predator yeah there's gonna be a
scene halfway through the predators like
you know what this isn't fair
this isn't even fun for me now okay i'll
take your weapons and i'll learn how to
fight like you do so it's an even fight
yeah there's gonna be more hand-to-hand
fights this time around when and how are
we going to get the requisite mud bath
scene there are beats that you need a
predator movie to hit and something like
you know figuring out the mud thing to
thwart the thermal vision is one of
those but i i really would like to maybe
be surprised by how they figure out the
situation and maybe thwart the predator
rather than falling back on okay like at
the end we're gonna see all the beats
that we know from predator and predators
and every other predator movie that
they've done we have to be just invested
in the characters that's something that
predator movies have a hard time doing
which is a good bridge like i really
hope this is able to bridge the gap for
that because they said like they you
know this isn't the kind of movie you
turn to for the utmost uh authenticity
but i do think it's cool that they
assembled a cast of almost entirely like
native american and first nations people
to lead a franchise blockbuster even if
it is gonna stream i really hope that
they they bring some actual uh vibrant
life out of that side of things to maybe
you know temper the things that we know
are gonna be there that aren't going to
be quite as fresh nor do i want it to
get bogged down in a bunch of predator
mythology yes make it very immediate
just make it super immediate you know
that's all i care about just a high
tension violent tense
hunt thriller it's all that's all it has
to be and it doesn't mean any more than
that but yeah guys what did you think
about the trailer leave your thoughts
down below hey let's do a
chase gardener chuck come on you know
how to do this chase name is chase
gardner
oh dude chase on the chase if there's
anyone looks like gardening
chase gardener okay i get to do it okay
okay so it's a chase like running after
chase
you're the perfect person for this
because your name is chase and then
people are being chased in this movie by
predator yeah
and they're in like the fully they're in
nature where gardening happens and
agriculture chase gardner
and the gardener maybe is being chased
during the movie
by a predator you lost it
i didn't tell you
give me another shot assisting you
though give me another shot i'll listen
to help you focus
give me another shot i'm so sorry don't
understand
i'm sorry i did not erase any of their
pledge
i am the real predator here
[Music]